- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
It was enhanced by making
solid eye contact with you
(audience laughing)
the whole way through.
You know that if an English person
maintains eye contact
with you for five seconds,
while drinking tea,
you turn English.
(audience laughing)
We are legally married then.
Either that or I owe you a country.
I dunno which one happens.
(audience laughing)
We got five suggestions
and then we'll drop a beat,
do a freestyle rap.
Where is our first suggestion coming from
on this side of the room?
There's a hand up here. So polite, yes?
- [Audience Member] "A day
in the life of a Mohel."
- A day in the life of a Mohel.
A Mohel is someone who
chops foreskins off right?
(audience laughing)
Okay, cool.
You impressed that I knew that word?
Yeah, you thought-
(audience laughing loudly)
You thought you were gonna catch me out.
You thought I only knew like Rabbi,
Rabbi Dick Chopper.
(audience laughing)
I know if your name was
Rabbi Richard Chopper,
that'd be pretty cool.
(audience laughing)
Back corner. What would
you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member]
Something about tea? Maybe?
- That's too obvious, isn' it?
(audience chuckling)
- [Audience Member] Disappointment.
- Disappointment?
Yes.
(audience laughing)
Tea-based disappointment
or in general?
(audience laughing)
- In general.
- In general? Cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
Disappointment in general, right?
Disappointment in general.
Mohels. Middle of the room.
- [Audience Member] Bisexuals.
- Bisexuals? Cool.
(audience member claps)
That is a sexuality.
Not glasses that let you
see near and far away.
(audience laughing)
Bisexuals.
Are you yourself Bisexual?
- Yes.
- And what about
bisexuality or bisexual-ism?
That's not a word. (chuckles)
(audience chuckling)
What bisexual-ism would
you like to focus on?
- [Audience Member] I don't
know. No one believes we exist.
- That's true. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bi-erasure is what it's called, right?
Which is a fact.
Okay, cool. People who don't
believe bisexuals exist.
(audience laughing)
People in this area,
what'd you like to rap about?
- [Audience Member] Abortion!
(audience laughing)
- Cool.
(audience clapping)
So far
we've got Mohels,
we've got disappointment,
we've got bisexuals not existing,
and we've got abortion.
(audience laughing)
Last suggestion guys.
And you've got a
high standards to live up to.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Squeegee!
- Squeegee.
(audience laughing)
Yeah. Yeah, that's good.
So a squeegee in British parlance is the
kind of thing that you scrape to like,
you know get wa'er off
shower walls and stuff.
That's what it is over here right?
- Yup.
- Cool.
That's cool that we
share some things, right?
(audience laughing)
You probably spell it without the u.
Like a prick, right?
(audience laughing)
S-Q-E-E-G-E-E
Okay, cool.
This tea is almost finished.
I need to neck that,
otherwise it's gonna be too cold
by the time the rap finishes.
But this is...
it's gonna be a freestyle.
That's a rap made up on the spot,
based entirely on those suggestions.
The suggestions are Mohels,
disappointment,
bisexuals not existing,
abortions and squeegees.
(audience laughing)
And I don't want you guys to worry.
'Cuz it's not gonna be
as toe-curlingly bad,
as you're expecting a privately educated,
middle class white British boy to be.
(audience laughing)
So I'll drop this beat for ya
('Trigger' beat begins)
We'll have some absolute fun.
It's gonna be delightful.
Nice.
('Trigger' lyrics begin)
♪ First word ♪
♪ But I disagree you ♪
♪ Which appearin' to me ♪
♪ And you saw the tea ♪
♪ I'm like nah ♪
♪ Too obvious ♪
♪ Need another one ♪
♪ Then the guy to you left ♪
♪ He has got it goin' on ♪
♪ He was like Chris ♪
♪ I know you're disappointed ♪
♪ The first of the phrase is my man give ♪
♪ And so how about that ♪
♪ Disappointment ♪
♪ I kinda understand what my man meant ♪
♪ He was like nah ♪
♪ I'm expecting the famous comic ♪
♪ Comin' to the stage here ♪
♪ He's dietin' on it ♪
♪ And just got you ♪
♪ And some of your ill ♪
♪ You were walking onstage with the tea ♪
♪ And the milk and you didn't even use ♪
♪ The full of the jug ♪
♪ Hopefully we set it off ♪
♪ Hopefully it's enough ♪
♪ And you will enjoy the show ♪
♪ Or at least my portion ♪
♪ Anyway bro ♪
♪ Never tell a girl to get an abortion ♪
♪ Unless she wants it ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ That's her own choice ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ People say it's my body my voice ♪
♪ And if you want abortion ♪
♪ Down in Texas ♪
♪ Well you bette' be quick ♪
♪ Bet'er check first your life ♪
♪ Before six weeks or five and a half ♪
♪ And if you're not ♪
♪ Do it yourself in the bubble bath ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Really sorry ♪
♪ Here go get the hange' ♪
♪ I'm just saying ♪
♪ You can grab a coat hange' ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ No don't do that ♪
♪ You'll damage ya inside ♪
♪ Go to Oklahoma ♪
♪ The clinics that provide ♪
♪ They will help you ♪
♪ They will get you unfilled ♪
♪ If it's after 10 weeks ♪
♪ Ya can't use a pill ♪
♪ That's a medical one ♪
♪ It's absurd ♪
♪ You only got'a get
inside and be so surgical ♪
♪ I hope that you enjoyed
the abortion instruction ♪
♪ You did if ya democrat ♪
♪ But not Republican ♪
♪ Big shock there ♪
♪ Like this isn't fun ♪
♪ It makes my blood boil ♪
♪ Like a Mohel's ♪
♪ Is not done ♪
♪ The jo- ♪
(audience laughing loudly)
♪ Lookin' in to the award ♪
♪ He says he's a Mohel ♪
♪ And I'm like ♪
♪ Are ya sure ♪
♪ He says ah yeah ♪
♪ Here's my little certificate ♪
♪ Display ♪
♪ I'm just like ♪
♪ What is even that blade ♪
♪ Ah ♪
♪ You look lazy sir ♪
(audience chuckling)
♪ He just come in with Gillette razor ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ And I'm like ♪
♪ How does this even chop off the tip ♪
♪ If you slip ♪
♪ Then my son will end up with no dick ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ And that's not a thing ♪
♪ That I want to ♪
♪ Inflict on anyone ♪
♪ Whether they're not ♪
♪ Or a Jew ♪
(audience laughs)
♪ So take care ♪
♪ Don't give it a mix ♪
♪ Where does the Mohel do his shit ♪
♪ Yeah, oh Brits ♪
♪ I know those words ♪
♪ Several of you didn't ♪
♪ You were like ah Chris ♪
♪ We'd be really hidden ♪
♪ We gonna get away the blood
from the bad circumcision ♪
♪ Kinda clean it up by using
all the surgical precision ♪
♪ With the squeegee ♪
(audience laughing loudly)
♪ And it's comin' ♪
♪ Parallel Squeegee ♪
♪ Like a PC ♪
♪ Like a mouse ♪
♪ I take it down ♪
♪ Takes me half an hour ♪
♪ To get out of the bathroom ♪
♪ When I'm takin' a shower ♪
♪ And my mum would shout ♪
♪ She would say ♪
♪ Chris what you into ♪
♪ Use the squeegee ♪
♪ Otherwise the mildew start
to accumulate all there ♪
♪ She like put the fan on ♪
♪ Circulate the air ♪
♪ I really wanna pause and
take a sip from my tea ♪
♪ So I will just hold a second ♪
♪ I've done me a world of good ♪
♪ Respect your for bein' silent ♪
♪ Like bisexuals ♪
♪ Do they exist ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ No one even knows ♪
♪ People say pick a side ♪
♪ Do you like girls or the bros ♪
♪ That's not a problem ♪
♪ You can respect them ♪
♪ I think we all agree ♪
♪ It's a spectrum ♪
♪ If your sexuality quivers on a Tuesday ♪
♪ And that the weekend ♪
♪ You say like I don't even care ♪
♪ I'm just desperate for a fuck ♪
♪ I'll be walking in the club ♪
(audience laughing loudly)
♪ I'll be looking you up ♪
♪ I'm like ah ♪
♪ Anyone who catches my eye ♪
♪ I'll fuck all of you here ♪
(audience laughing)
♪ Probably this guy ♪
(audience cheering loudly)
(audience laughing and clapping)